i was in high school and we were looking
at a film and they were
looking at the the degradation of
homelessness and disparity and i said
wow man those people are really [ __ ]
up
i'll never end up like that and about
two years ago i was on one of the back
streets here and
on skid row and uh it dawned on me
what i said and i said i'll be down
i became one of those people
all right norman norman where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
i'm originally from detroit michigan and
tell me about your family you had both
parents growing up
i know i had one parent i didn't know my
father didn't meet him uh until the
day before my 18th birthday um
came out here grew up in the country
club park district of los angeles
i'm 14 months old
went to 24th street school had very two
very smart sisters
that i had to follow behind i always
liked to read
i got straight a's in elementary school
september the 2nd 1976
devastating i watched my mother take her
last breath
she died of a massive cerebral
hemorrhage
my grandmother came from detroit to uh
take me back you saw this yes how old
were you
i was 12 years old 12 years old um
my grandmother um she went back to
detroit yes went back to detroit uh
described my grandma a little bit six
foot two and a half 295 pound
sequoia indian born in moosehead
saskatchewan canada
very strict um i wouldn't say mean
but very ruly uh
when i was 15 years old something
devastating happened to me a family
friend
molested me uh threw me down and
inserted
himself in me i never told anybody
never told anybody um
graduated from high school detroit
northern high school straight a's
most likely to succeed and best dressed
one uh the adelaide stephenson award to
go to
baylor university graduated in three
years with a bachelor's of science in
computer science
i before then applied for the first
chrysler award
i won it went to michigan
um graduated uh magnum [ __ ] laude
and i started working for ford motor
company um
switched over to general dynamics it was
more money
when i was about 24 and a half 25 i
discovered crack cocaine
uh my first time i went and drew uh 5
000
out of the bank uh didn't go back to
work
and that started my downfall um
i've put myself in very precarious
situations um
gay men have come up to me and asked me
uh for sexual favors and i've done it
i lost my grandmother in 1985 which was
another blow
and you're not gay no and i'm not gay at
all uh
totally totally straight uh never been
nobody's ever inserted himself into me
with the exception of the guy who
molested me but i've put myself in
positions to where
i'm thank god that i don't have hiv
uh you're looking at a person who's um
who's had it all through the course of
my addiction i've lost
uh six houses one condo five cars
um my average salary is anywhere from 95
to 245
000 a year
and now you're living on the street yeah
and now i'm living on the streets um
my nightly routine usually consists of
going on the uh
metro rail to either long beach or santa
monica because they're the longest ones
and
once they put you off of that then i'll
get on the bus either the
33 or the 60. and i'll ride it's safer
to ride a bus or a train
yes yes then to be on the streets i mean
you know you have so many precarious
situations that happen
it's a catch this catch can when you're
homeless you never know what's gonna
happen you never know
what's the next move is um
so i've been a crack cocaine addict for
the best better part of 30 to 33 years
um
you have kids i have four kids um
ranging from uh 32 years old to nine
um of course right now they're uh
they don't hear from me i had a phone
and um i was jonesing and i sold my
phone
after i spent 253 dollars to get it
so uh i mean it is what it is um
i've been in recovery before i've been
in about 55 different treatment centers
the longest lifting sobriety i ever had
was six years 10 months and two days
i blew that because i got cocky i
thought i had it and
i haven't been able to muster up 90 days
since and that's been about
18 19 years ago
i mean uh homelessness is systemic uh
it's
something that you really um don't plan
on
but you quickly learn how to adapt and
survive
well when i was young i was 16 years old
i think we were
i was in high school and we were looking
at a film and they were looking at
the degradation of homelessness and
disparity and i said wow man those
people are really [ __ ] up
i'll never end up like that and about
two years ago i was on one of the back
streets here and
on skid row and uh it dawned on me
what i said and i said i'll be down
i'm one of those people but i looked at
the fact that i said those
people so i categorized somebody well
everybody's human
everybody makes mistakes everybody has
downfalls um
it's up to you right now do i want to
quit using drugs
my heart says yes but my body says no
because i have the type of disease that
centers in my head and
at a moment's whim i could be doing good
i've walked off jobs
i've stolen from jobs um i have a slew
of employers who've wondered what the
hell happened because here's a guy with
all of this potential
um i've worked here on skid row before
only to go back
time and time again do i know what the
future holds no i'm not god
do i believe in god yes do i pray yes
what i was once told when i was a young
kid about my grandmother um
that god will give you whatever's in
your heart so if drugs are in my heart
that's exactly what i'm going to get
if i want to change it's up to me but i
really
really have to really want it right now
do i want it
i'll be honest no but
to be quite honest i really don't know
what the hell i want
so i'm at one of those pinnacle
crossroads in life
so damned if you do damned if you don't
so i really don't know what the [ __ ] i
want to do how do you support yourself
now
well i get uh i get general relief i get
food stamps which i usually sell every
month
and then i have to put myself in a
position where i have to go on food
lines which i
don't have to you get 194 worth of food
stamps
you sell them for 100 bucks you buy
crack you buy weed
you buy beer you buy cigarettes you're
broke
this usually happens um if i get some
bad dope it usually happens within hours
if i get some good dope it might take a
couple of days
um am i employable i believe i am
employable but with this addiction
no i'm not no way uh first check
they had a nickname for me in um the
rooms of uh
cocaine anonymous they used to call me
one check norman
because every time i would get a job i
get sober i get a job
first check i'm gone that's it
and that's happened for the last
14 years
you're a rare case of someone who's
educated and successful and then
ended up here at the bottom yeah what
what do you think most people don't
understand you know most most people
outside of this world
don't understand about addiction it's
it's strength the power
it's very very powerful anytime um
your mind can convince you to [ __ ]
yourself without permission without
your permission that's bad and this has
happened time and time again but i have
no control
over it um it's something that centers
right in my mind
you know i could be doing good one
minute i might do good for months
but there's going to come a day and i
know it is something stressful something
it's sometimes majority of the times
it's always something that
nudges me to that um
one time my daughter didn't want to talk
to me for some reason i went and used
um i got into an argument with a
co-worker i went and used
um it could be anything
the bus driver could piss me off i'll
get off the bus before my stop
and go to the dope house it really
doesn't matter i think people just don't
really understand
how powerful uh the disease of addiction
is it's extremely powerful
do you think there's anything in your
childhood like what happened with the
the sexual abuse or anything like that
or do you think it was the environment
that you were having
well i grew up in a damn good
environment in detroit i was
uh basically sequestered but somebody
introduced you to crack okay
yes it was uh i actually volunteered at
a
homeless shelter called cots it was on
michigan and trumbull
right by the old tiger stadium and this
little girl used to come up to me all
the time and i'd give her a candy and
then her mom came up to me
and she actually talked to me about her
story
and i felt real bad and i moved her in
with me
and um one time her cousin had a problem
at home and
they needed somewhere to stay and i
brought them there and one day i came
home and they were smoking crack
the room door was locked and i said no i
don't want any they offered it to me i
said no
i said that for three consecutive days
the fourth day i tried it
that was 1986.
this is 2020. since
then it's been an up and down battle
a zigzag um i call it sometimes
perpetual rondo
it's up it's down it's in between
so people that know me um
have always said you have a wealth of
intelligence
well i've all come to realize that i'm
probably the smartest dumbest
[ __ ] i've ever met in my life
that's the shame but it's the truth see
i've come to a point to where i'm a
realist and i understand
what i suffer from i don't understand it
fully but i understand it enough that
it's more powerful to me and
will i do this till i die i don't know
do i want to die
a cocaine addict no i don't do i want my
kids to be mad at me like they are now
no i don't
do i want um all this [ __ ] that's
happened to me no i don't
it's um it's really [ __ ] up when
somebody
of the same sex forces you
into something um even now you know my
eyes are almost
welting up because you just don't do
that to somebody
i think that's one of the reasons why i
use
uh even having sex with
other men i've questioned my own
sexuality
am i gay no i'm not but i needed a hit
and they offered me money and i knew i
could get a hit
so i did it am i proud of it hell no
but um i think the more and more i talk
about it the freer i'll get and um
hopefully and prayerfully uh somebody
will see this and understand
that guess what you can have it all
i've been to park avenue now i'm on a
park bench
i've had the riches now i have rags
but it's up to me choice is mine
have you talked about these things
before
no no not really um people only know
about
my schooling um
they don't they know about my family
my last name is uh fondren
i'm not even gonna say anything about
that i'll just have you look up the last
name
it's a family that dates back to 12 18.
it's a family that has a family crest
it's a family that's
extremely prominent
um i have not lived up to that building
i was bred and coded to do that
but for some reason i got um attracted
to the street life
because it was something i was always
told not to do
and it seemed like as i'm going to
church as
a young kid with my grandmother and as
i'm being sequestered and have to come
in when the lights are on everybody else
is having fun
thank god for my grandmother she warned
me everything she ever told me
has come true she said if you get with
those people
you're going to be exactly like those
people and the only way you're going to
go
is down and that's what has happened
have you lost touch with all your
friends and family and things like that
my immediate friends uh yes they don't
they don't really want to be bothered
anymore because they know that i'm going
to lie about something and get some
money
my family um my oldest sister
understands a little bit my middle
sister
we don't have the relationship we used
to have based on the fact that i stole
her wedding ring and her husband's
wedding ring after she sent for me
to come out here in the first place how
did i repay her
just like i repaid everybody else just
like i've done everybody else
[ __ ] them when the disease says go
i go
what do you think the solution is to
your situation what would help you
if you if you were ready to change and
wanted to what do you think would
be the first step well i think the first
step is being honest with myself and
understanding that uh
i do have an addiction um
i do have a disease and um
understanding this more powerful than i
am i mean i do in some respects but i
don't respect that [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] if i could take a
hit right now i would
do i want one right now you damn right i
do because that's just how it is um
but i gotta be honest within myself and
be willing
to stop and be willing to change
am i afraid of that change yes i do have
fear of the unknown i've come to grips
with that
if i don't if i can't see it taste it
and feel it i ain't [ __ ] with it
but yet again i act on faith if they say
faith is the substance of things hoped
for and the evidence of things not seen
a friend comes around the corner his
eyes are wide
you know he said hey man they got some
bomb now it's the substance of things
hoped for
so i'm hoping to get like him the
evidence of things not seen i didn't see
the crack
but i went and i acted in faith so faith
works in various ways you got to really
look at that and
i just got to be willing to change i got
to be willing to want to stop getting
high period
it's just not crack i don't need
anything if i drink a beer
i'm going to smoke some rocks if i smoke
some weed i'm going to smoke some rocks
if i think about smoking some rocks i'm
going to smoke some rocks
so i got to be honest with myself and i
got to be willing inside of here
to say hey norman enough is enough you
were thinking 56 years old that i would
learn
it doesn't look like it what's the most
important
thing you've learned from your years on
the street how to survive
um it's a [ __ ] being hungry
um hunger is something that's very very
[ __ ] up
i it doesn't get to the depths of the uh
the third world countries where people
are starving starving but i've been
hungry
uh i've ran out of rouse with a fully
cooked slab of ribs
baby back ribs uh chicken i went in 99
cent stores and
ditched the security guard and stolen
candy just to eat
uh i've eaten out of the garbage can
i've seen a drink at a bus stop
and i've looked around and i've drink it
because i was thirsty
but two days earlier i just had four or
five hundred dollars
so i've learned how to survive
most importantly
what regrets do you have
my regret is um
july the 19th 1986
that's when i took my first hit i regret
doing that
i've often looked back and said you know
if i would have never
done that but you know if if was the
fifth we'd always be drunk you know i'll
be drunk you know this is the cliches go
on and on but
if i would have never taken that where
would i be now
at that time i was working for general
dynamics
i was 23 and a half
24 making 74 000 a year
had one of the best apartments that you
could see in in in detroit the
jeffersonian
that's where i stayed right down on
jefferson i look over my balcony i'm
looking at windsor canada and the
detroit river
now i'm looking at rats i'm smelling
piss and i'm stepping over people
and i'm scrub struggling every day to
survive
i'm struggling every day to eat i'm
struggling every day to smoke a
cigarette
i'm struggling every day to get a hit
my regret is july 19 1986.
do you see any signs that you're getting
close to making a change
well i think it's uh i don't know um
i was talking to my buddy and i was like
easily looked at me
this morning he said man what's wrong
i said man i'm really getting tired of
this
it's a norm i've known you for a long
time
you said man you smart you come out of
it i said it ain't got a goddamn thing
to do with intelligence
it has everything to do with wherewithal
and
i think god and i have a problem
yep because i'm a mama's boy
yeah and um it always happens you know
when i talk about my mom because
that was a that was [ __ ] up you know
that i had to
watch that
i always think about her
was lighter way lighter than me and i
look just like her
um and a lot of times i think you know
she's really not proud of me
you know
so that's it we uh we're gonna do our
best all right now well good luck man
okay great speaking with you
wow that's the first time
you